how's it going Rosa - welcome back do
not say anything did last episode
concrete crap on it's a trap man Hank
let us out here so August he could kill
us still don't see why he would do that
to us
good point can't go there
goddamn he really that Hank I really set
us out to trap oh he killed him for us
well that's nice I'm coming
I can't brofist anymore what do I do
shouldn't we call Eugene Ursa ah oh oh
is it with you guys at Auto turrets oh
jeez how are we gonna do this please
don't shoot out right in the face
I'll they have a bunch of criminals down
there poor souls can't fight anything in
like this can we make it come on come on
oh that was close I'm trying oh god it's
gonna be boss about all the time Oh No
Oh No yeah yeah yeah good thing I see a
bazooka freakin awesome
that worked hah I flinched it's still
Mike that's weird
no we couldn't trust him okay okay you
were right if I listened to you we
wouldn't even be here
oh they gotta use me as long as we are
here we should save those two how are
you gonna get us out of here I'm gonna
shoot you down sounds like a plan
don't flinch oh god what's happening oh
thanks Oh No holy [ __ ] my god yes
[Music]
or we're fighting her now yeah [ __ ]
dates oh my god what does she have I
can't hurt her
if I destroy all this stuff no I can't
fight her Melia anyway but how am I
supposed to do B oh nice
got that [ __ ] sick oh that kick amazing
oh that felt good
let me uh got it
gotta sit the [ __ ] down here comes the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] a bomb up your a-hole
taste it I kind of missed whatever where
is she
yes
[ __ ] pigs
where's he going
she is scared getting her lapdogs
there's more coming so they come in
waves I'm okay with that
I got plenty of smokes for your girls
holy [ __ ] how much do they take there
you go
finish it oh never mind
Oh God who's this is that her yeah it's
on it's so [ __ ] on it's never been
this on I'd literally just hit the on
button it's been off this entire
playthrough that's how [ __ ] on it by
the power of smoke Jess oh can I use TV
power now I can use TV power now I don't
really need it by [ __ ] it there you go
the shields down shields down spray and
pray on that bitch's Bay oh no she blew
it up [ __ ]
we're in deep [ __ ] now Bruce not the
good kind of [ __ ] I don't know which
kind of [ __ ] would be good [ __ ] dude if
you would stop moving so goddamn much
that'd be great thank you
dang got hurt there we go
almost down dang it first
sorry what she's still up what is she
made of frickin concrete oh yeah [ __ ]
let's just hope this works
shotgun shell days a lot more risky but
hey what are you gonna do wait I saw
that we can suck something oh we have
neat we have okay shooting there's still
hope for a ChaCha's there we go
holy [ __ ] she's [ __ ] [ __ ] up
everything I hate you so much
yes you want to taste it then taste
stuff sorry I'm I'm letting this game
get ahead of me oh yes why give me the
neon heading in the direction of the
concrete tower that is served as our
headquarters as the DUP arrival nearly
two weeks ago but so far our efforts to
reach miss Augustine have produced no
response and now we're getting reports
of scattered demonstrations by local
citizens and support at the DUP
demanding that the bioterrorist uprising
in Seattle be ended by any means
necessary
for us oh [ __ ] I can't be good now we're
at Paragon no way we always wear a
Paragon where you haven't become a hero
yet what's going on here Bruce can't
believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] kill our
brother I forever hate this girl now
before I was like maybe she just had a
rough childhood now there's no excuse I
bet we will see her story once we take
her powers I hope there's a good ending
to this cuz [ __ ] is really bad right now
I'm sorry you know you told me not to
trust Hank but I didn't listen
he always is the best in people that's
why we're paying Daughtry I know he made
a deal with them
kind of [ __ ] up
give me the power of smoke god I'm going
Batman on these [ __ ] Joyner sniper
clang oh god I fell off the map oh god
what happened uh okay what is this is
this the matrix I don't want to go there
no no no get back what the [ __ ] where am
I
what oh my god way to ruin the mood what
a bust he'll probably I know he's alive
oh I was supposed to do that I didn't
know before
his numbers got to be in the incoming
call log gotcha why am i building to use
your phone okay I'll do that we should
probably get the TV power then if I can
find it there we go
give me dad give me that television
power girl there you go alright let's
track it I get the feeling we haven't
seen the last of ng and Angie [ __ ]
don't know hopefully that hangeth
something else a freakin war
damn yeah maybe more bioterrorist join
in whoa damn what is happening there I'm
not afraid of you Hank
maybe I should be
there you go where's your shell mr.
turtle ow not Michel your boyfriend your
shell dad damn there we go he said oh we
got to go back up screw these guys all
really 10 10 meters let's do it a lot of
people here a lot of Deputies there we
go what's up ladies throw fists power of
Somozas the most powerful sniper
climbing the world it will all subdue so
easy
oh yeah yeah I'd be getting close this
look at this tracker one more shot
heading to a marina running out of dry
land
I'd say me an old Hank about to meet up
again
all right it's time to settle this
bioterrorist alibi pay or Ellie's hello
Joey my sniper claim oh hey Hank
fancy meeting you here bet you're gonna
[ __ ] dice what you believe but I never
heard tell kill the Condor my brother
would still be alive if it wasn't for
you
oh god damn it I wanted to murder him I
can't kill him now
oh it isn't okay I really wanted to kill
him I was ready to kill him but he has a
daughter I don't know man
if he was doing it to save his daughter
then then I can understand I mean enough
killing
she's not gonna grow up without a dad
just because I wanted revenge I don't
think my brother would have wanted it
either so we're gonna spare him for the
sake of our brother [ __ ] sucks man
at least whip his ass
why don't you just come with us now [ __ ]
off disappear
Stacy thank
Oh coming honey
[Music]
let's go home better make me into a
hereafter that freaking godly decision
uh this gay man a scam it's time to get
what I came for Augustine
it's on
kidding me I'm the one who's been
protecting society from her in her army
of freaks so the people are coming with
us
I wonder how like me as a character
would change depending on the choices I
made in this game are they helping me to
kill them
ha ha ha that's also all right we have
one rent oh they're kicking them awesome
so how do I get over there go to DUP
tower it's over there how do how do I
get over there yeah on this thing this
flying
I'm supposed to use this right there we
go oh my god it works all the way across
the sky yeah yeah hopefully it won't
fall short uh come on yeah that's
amazing
let's subdue some [ __ ] hmm it's
behind you would you like some back
massage there you go
I like to use knifes while I do it
I love how the people are helping me
it's awesome I have so many fangirls
look at your eyes ah what who did that
yeah
polish a there : Bolton before by doing
[Music]
you got it back massage these people
have seen us both in action they want
justice will be my head on the platter
thanks fangirls appreciate it
mangoes are the best man hi senator
thing that you want doesn't take her
alive show the world what she's done
just kill her for what she did the right
this is a decision okay lady time for
the world to see what you really are
yeah show her mean their panties she
doesn't look half as famished people
can't work with that even if the rest of
it is still active
holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] tower man damn
well we're gonna do some climbing
breasts it's gonna be fun alright Prez I
am sorry we have to end the episode
there next episode is gonna be the last
episode to get pumped it's gonna be
awesome
thank you for liking this video Bros and
I'll see you in the next one as always
stay awesome bros bro